pop
I'm not going to look at you
you're a man of principle and excellence
I know you weren't trying to be
courageous
when you hired me
but you did do something nobody else in
professional sports has ever done
Q display Excellence you expect
excellence and model how to become
excellent in your everyday routine and
how you go about your work
you spoke courage into me with a phone
call as I was getting ready to coach
that first summer league team in 2015.
he said just be you you're going to be
great and you've texted me that I don't
even know if you know how many times
you've actually texted me that just be
you just be you just be you
and you've changed the traction of my
life and of so many other girls and
young women
thank you I love you
[Music]
foreign